this is your classic example where like
I had been saying it think geometrically
as much as you possibly can but don't
leave behind or your algebraic skills
because they'll serve you very well when
you have a look at this okay when we got
I'm gonna thinking about some modulus
the mitosis or whatever this complex
number is or it's comprised on P is
complex I'm a square conjugates squared
take the difference so before we begin
what looks like a reasonable way to sort
of starts simplify this algebraically
any any tips
yeah rapid answers okay now rush nailed
it you've won but he didn't see this so
quickly this is a difference of squares
like it's an a squared take away B
squared okay now if you didn't see this
quickly is wrapped it like the very
first time I met any question like this
my thought was well that X plus iy and
that's X minus iy so I'm just gonna I
just square them and they just see what
happens okay
in a work by the way it will just take
another four or five lines and once it
opportunities on you make errors to
creep in difference of squares is smug
let's write down but the question is why
is difference of squares such a clever
way to go in fact what clues did the
question itself give you apart from the
squares themselves the difference of
squares is a better way to go any
suggestions the conjugates
right but what is that what what
significance does that have turned Y
difference of squares okay so because
what's different between these two
things is the imaginary part has gone
plus or minus plus or minus we know the
reason why conjugates are useless
because when you are when you combine
them in lots of different ways one part
would disappear right the real part will
vanish or the imaginary part managed
watch as each one takes the term Z minus
2z bar then take away its conjugate
this is X plus iy take away X minus iy
right so you can see that I'm gonna have
X take away X the real pot disappears
okay and I get left with double to Y
doubled the imaginary part okay with
that hoping to do the extra line of
working to show you okay so that's fine
when you do this when you add them the
plus or minus the imaginary parts
they're gonna cancel now right so you
just get left with X plus X double the
real part right so this is like so okay
with that three then four and now you
can see why they stuck in a sneaky for
their friend like why I was to get
reducible so now I can type in stuff
okay now we've come to the limit of
where algebraic simplification can take
us right now I want to start getting
towards a locus right I want a
relationship
excuse me between x and y what a
relationship right so um how do you work
out the modules to this complex number
I'll give you him
yes what is the real POTUS there's no
real pot plus the imaginary pot happy
with that so now I've got the square
root of square square root of square
what's that
I'll give you a clue it's not a what's
the absolute value of a right why is it
the absolute value of a because that's
right when you square it you lose the
sign and then when you square it you
only get the positive okay so hence give
me a positive value only so what you're
really getting out of this is this guy
okay now we've used the definition of a
modulus but where do I go with that okay
now remember we use this strategy over
there again when you look at a question
you like chorus I have no idea what to
do with that okay you think about
simpler examples right so if I gave you
peace sorry most of us would know what
to do with that right what would you do
first this is a legion I would take this
as an equality right y cos x plus 1 and
I would say the relationship between the
inequality and the equation used what is
the relationship this is just a line
right but it's not just any line if the
boundary of this guy right do you agree
with that and in fact Y is greater than
so it'll be it'll be above okay so you
put your X plus 1 line in and then you
can say all right well now I just work
out whether I'll I'm in this side or
this side and then I'll show you the
coordinate right so when I have a look
at this the boundary of this this is a
region that we shaded but the boundary
like this yeah okay now I'm ready to
split never to split okay excuse me
now again we're not all that familiar
with this but if I took away the
absolute value actually it's not
something that's rocket science just XY
equals one I can divide both sides by X
by the way why can I divide both sides
by X because X can't possibly be equal
to zero right because zero times
something can't be equal to one right so
I can say that that's right I know
exactly what that looks like right so if
this needs me here where's this gonna be
let's think about it the simple case
right in what cases in what cases is
that simply equal to this
it's when x and y are both positive
that's not the only place it'll go if
they're both negative right because if
if they're both positive then the inside
is positive if you'll just get X Y if
they're both negative the inside will
also be positive so you just get X Y
right
so for now by the way we have a way of
saying okay when both Nixon by a
positive when we have about how we
describe that's why we would say first
question right transponder where's the
spot with everything negative which
conveniently is exactly where y equals
whatever X usually exists anyway you
came with that so let's just write that
down
this is y equals 1 of X where X Y is
greater than zero namely the first and
third wardress okay
but then there's the other case right
where it's not just whatever X it's
minus whatever X where is that the case
it's in the second and fourth but Y the
second and fourth in the second quadrant
right you've got x- and y positive so
the product will be negative which is
what gives you the negative case and
vice versa in the fourth quadrant you've
got X positive and Y negative so again
only one of them is negative so the
product is negative excuse me
so we get the negative case so I'm going
to say that where X Y is negative namely
the second and fourth
okay awesome so now I'm ready to graph
these boundaries right
am i including the boundaries are by
excluding them I'm excluding right
because you can see right up here
there's no equality there it's not great
an irregular for it's just greater than
I so let's draw to standardise here you
go okay yes sir don't get overwhelmed by
this is it water on there let's just do
it step by step remember the first and
third quarters they go together second
and fourth quarters go together let's
just do it
what's that bit of time what is your
intuition tell you now I'm going to pull
you all the way back to this line here
this line he'll be back in like this is
all this is cartesian terms yeah just
think back to what this means in complex
numbers right what is a module what's
the definition of a modulus distance
from the origin right distance from the
origin now what I'm measuring is the
distance from the origin to this point
distance from the origin to this point
and I want that distance to be bigger
than one I want to be 105 or 100 or
anything like that okay
so BAM the origin is here and I want big
distances not little ones and he's my
boundary which side of this battery
would you guess that I should be on I
should be on the outside right
your intuition should tell you I want
distances that I've begun okay
let's confirm this right what I need is
a point inside my boundary and a point
outside just to really confirm that I
know what I'm doing okay
so frizzes here's a point on the
boundary
right what's a nice easy point that's on
this boundary now we would usually say
point one right but this is not a
Cartesian plane right so really I should
say is one plus I that's on the boundary
that's no you stood by the testing that
I already know it's going to be excluded
okay pick a point for me a nice easy
point that's inside the battery a zero
zero is not gonna be any good right well
I should just say fewer right because
complex plane okay zero isn't there good
because here is not defined for any of
these rights are cutting quick can you
put it not gonna be happy
give me something else okay so if what
plus I is on then okay 1 plus 1/2 I is
on the inside
before we finish give me a nice easy
point that's on the outside how about
okay now I'm just thinking for dress let
me go just straight up and I don't need
to a points of fractions I'm only
appealing to fractions to fit in here
I'm just gonna go 1 plus 2i that's gonna
be outside right you go ahead and you
test on Monday morning will confirm and
we'll draw a seam together